the book ends trying to summarize look
when the hits the fan and some of
these places are going to run into
problems and you and I have walked
through some of the reasons why some of
these places are going to run into
problems uh you know you have kicking
obligations down down the road you have
overlying on federal aid that's a
one-time thing uh you might have your
commercial uh tax base uh erode uh you
know some people might be voting with
their feet in various ways so then
starts getting dark and then you have to
make the big Choice among the three
options and you lay out some of the the
principles for what one should do so the
three choices to review good fun is bail
out
austerity
or default and I'm going to like just
give you my personal outlook on this is
that I remember when things were going
bad and I spent time in Detroit when
they were declaring bankruptcy uh they
were they were doing some things where
you're like wow it's rough like they
they have a art collection and they just
sell it to try and meet their
obligations and at the last minute one
of the local philanthropists came in and
bought it because they were about to
like you know have their Art Museum
looted I mean it's pretty you know and
you could look at it and be like well
you know art not so bad but like they're
they're other things um when you're in a
rough time
um it seems like firing more people is
not the best move
um you know like you don't want to add
fuel to a bad fire
um so so to speak I totally understand
the moral hazard issue because it's like
everyone's just like hey let's just
spend spend spend and then anytime we
get into trouble it's like the bailout
comes
um uh and so it feels like the
um managed process
of like a quasi bankruptcy default
um is like a middle of the road move the
problem then is that lenders get sad and
say you know what I'm not going to give
you guys as much fun as much money uh
now I like that that strikes me as the
least problematic just in the sense that
um like there are a lot of problems why
we have a hard time building
um and I'm sure financing is one issue
but it doesn't strike me as the main
issue it seems like the main issue is
around like the over regulation the
layers the complexity the the capture
the corruption probably uh you know like
that that's attended so anyway that that
those are my two cents on the big three
of uh of the bailout austerity and
default so I mean I think my preferences
are take two forms on this I mean so
again I in the book I think the
situation will depend so it'll depend a
little bit which one you prefer
um uh um and so I don't give a single
one answer to rule them all type type uh
type of answer but I think that what you
can do is adopt uh balance Solutions and
then you can add conditions to some of
your support that help avoid problems
going forward so what do I mean by
balance Solutions so things like
bankruptcy but also things like giving
federal aid to both states and cities at
the same time
um can result in um a little default a
little a little austerity and a little
moral hazard and that that has the the
fact that they're small amounts rather
than large amounts there's kind of
declining marginal harms and so in the
Detroit instance the as you know the
philanthropist came through was called
the Grand bargain after bankruptcy they
came through with a bunch of money to
support the art museum but the Steep
which had been kind of holding out and
and not been super friendly to Detroit
also gave a lot of money in matching the
philanthropist money but they did it
after a bankruptcy have been declared
and the result was they didn't create
too much moral hazard because who would
want to go through bankruptcy just to
get fairly that's crazy our state that's
that's crazy on the other hand it
mitigated the harms of the bankruptcies
the pensioners just didn't do that badly
between the philanthropist Aid and the
state aid um they would have done even
better if the federal government offered
a little bit too as President Obama
wanted to do and so this kind of
balanced approach attractive the other
thing I think is really attractive is
that the federal government is going to
give money and realistically it is given
in the last two big crises particularly
during covet it gave an enormous amount
of money it should attach some
conditions to that money in order to
encourage states to do a little
bettering so what do I mean if the
federal money hits it you can get this
Federal money or you can get other
streams of federal money the state
federal government's giving states and
cities money all the time
um in return though you have to budget
in accordance with a gap with uh
generally accepted accounting principles
or you have to accept what Connecticut
put into its Bond the Covenant into its
bonds which are a volatility cap they
put a couple covenants but one was about
which if you're getting a one-time
amount of money you have to save a
certain percentage of it and the
conditionality
um can help you avoid the problems going
forward so take advantage of the fact
that you're doing something you'd rather
not do which is this Aid
um in return to get some conditionality
and so that has two nice effects one is
that the conditions hopefully are good
them themselves but secondly the
conditions are painful and so it makes
taking Aid Less Pleasant than it might
otherwise be it's not a free lunch
um and so one of the things I mean so
the federal aid during covid to states
and cities was almost certainly too
large it was you know it certainly has
helped to kick off inflation they took a
fire hose out they just went more and
like you know I I got it and now you
were saying hey at least it could have
been a conditional fire hose
and it probably should have been you
know like less of a firehouse Super
Soaker but you know whatever um one of
the interesting one of the reasons it's
so big was because they were trying to
avoid the moral hazard problem so one of
them because they give it to everywhere
every place but not every place had a
physical problem but they just gave
money to everybody
um and the that helps reduce moral
hazard because you're not rewarding a
jurisdiction for Behavior right you
exist here you go but you are just
splashing out the cash so those are the
principles which is I think they should
attempt the federal government when it's
facing one of these prices it you're
gonna bear or make a bad choice it's
gonna be a choice that's painful but you
can build things into it to make it a
balanced bad choice let's say just a
little bad across a number of dimensions
and you can use it to create situations
such that we are
um more um we're less likely to see
these problems going forward
[Music]
foreign